what's going on guys this is rob and i'm
sure by now most of you have seen the
trailer for thor 11 thunder which looks
great and you probably noticed that zeus
makes an appearance so for this episode
of beyond omega level we're going to go
over the origin powers and some of the
most impressive feats of zeus as he
exists in the marvel comics universe so
marvel's version of zeus was created by
stan lee and jack kirby and first
appeared in journey into mystery annual
number one in 1965 or at least the
version that we're going to see in the
movie did the character of zeus was
actually used in comics that were
published by marvel prior to this but
this is the one that remains a part of
the marvel mythos so the first time we
see zeus he basically breaks up a fight
between his son hercules and thor but
his actual origin goes back a lot
further of course marvel adapted zeus
from the greek mythological being but
within the marvel continuity zeus's
origin can be traced back to earth's
infancy and an entity known as the
demiurge which was basically a sentient
embodiment of the earth's biosphere
they're part of the earth's atmosphere
that can support life anyway the
demiurge basically spawned the elder god
including gaia also known as mother
earth but one of the elder gods named a
tomb left earth but after leaving his
energies were absorbed which gave rise
to the beings that would become gods
including the olympians as for gaia she
gave birth to a being named uranus who
she then mated with and then gave birth
to the titans the entities that would
birth the olympian gods yeah i mean it's
kind of messed up not gonna lie but
anyway one of the titans named cronus
killed his father orenos and then began
sending his own children to the
underworld however one of the children
basically escapes this fate thanks to
his mother rhea transporting him to
earth near mount olympus and greece
where he would be raised by shepherds of
course this child would grow up to be
zeus who would eventually free his
siblings from the underworld defeat his
father and the rest of the titans and
then finally marry his sister hera and
become the ruler of olympus he would
also father several children with his
sister including some prominent marvel
characters like hercules and ares some
of the most kentucky based mythology in
the history of the world i could say
that because i used to live in kentucky
i was not one of those people like that
in kentucky but you go far enough east
you're going to find them now for his
powers zeus possesses incredible
strength now just to get an idea of how
strong he is not only was zeus able to
lift a mountain above his head but he's
put his strength on display against some
of marvel's strongest characters for
example zeus was able to overpower thor
with very little difficulty and was even
able to restrain thor's hammer mjolnir
but only for a brief moment he also
overpowers neymar and she-hulk knocks
out his son ares with one punch and
beats his son hercules nearly to death
now when zeus battled the hulk not only
was he victorious but he actually broke
the hulk's ribs and caused his lungs to
collapse and the fight between the two
of them which zeus won easily destroyed
a mountain now zeus was also able to
nearly knock over galactus with one of
his punches but it's worth noting that
galactus was in need of nourishment at
the time so he was not at like his peak
level of power but in addition to his
strength zeus has insane levels of
durability he was able to battle thor
for several months during which time he
would have taken an incredible amount of
damage and not only did he survive all
that damage but he actually emerged from
that battle with the victory he shrugged
off attacks from namor which doesn't
really matter monica rambo he also
shrugged off attacks from her ares and
nova and was completely unfazed by an
attack from thor silver surfer damon
hellstrom and cersei the eternal now
zeus was also able to survive a blast
that killed several sky fathers which is
the term used in marvel comics to refer
to the heads of the various divine
pantheons including zeus odin and those
guys and he was even able to survive the
detonation of a bomb capable of creating
a black hole so it's virtually
impossible to harm this guy now in
addition to his physical attributes zeus
is able to control the weather most
notably possessing the ability to summon
and manipulate lightning as he wishes
now one bolt of zeus's lightning was
enough to incapacitate monica rambo who
is herself a beyond omega level
character on another occasion zeus took
out the entire avengers team including
monica rambo she hulk and namor black
knight and thor all with a single bolt
of light zeus's lightning bolts can also
destroy mountains and even tear the
world apart now when zeus battled
galactus he was able to knock him down
with one lightning strike and has done
the same to thor and hulk he was also
able to illuminate a world of total
darkness now zeus has a variety of other
powers most of which come from his vast
mystical abilities these include
teleportation shape-shifting including
size manipulation the ability to project
himself into the astral plane and the
ability to give and take powers from
others zeus is also able to manipulate
matter being able to defy the laws of
physics by making rocks thrown at him
vanished from existence he's also a
powerful telekinetic and can actually
take away and restore the memories of
others now zeus is so powerful that we
even gain insight from other characters
who comment on his power level for
instance thanos once placed zeus
alongside odin who he's often compared
to in terms of power level as being
equal to marvel's cosmic abstracts and
another comparison dormammu one of the
most powerful villains in all of marvel
comics declared that zeus is actually
his equal now zeus has not been used by
marvel nearly as much as other
characters close to his power level like
odin but it is impossible to deny how
powerful this guy is both thanos and
thor have placed zeus on the same level
as odin who's well beyond omega level
meaning that zeus certainly belongs in
that tier as well and when you also
consider that zeus has been able to hold
his own against galactus and is also
able to rip the world to pieces if he
chose then it's pretty clear this guy is
one of the most powerful characters but
we don't know how much of him will see
in thor love and thunder but let me know
in the comments whether you guys think
we'll see a small cameo or you think the
introduction of zeus into the mcu is a
way for characters like hercules and
ares to be introduced as well but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end thank you all for
watching i know it's short but i will
catch you all later that's what she said
peace